Hi. Good morning. Good morning. Sorry that was boomy. How are you? I got up early.
What is happening? I went and I saw my mom and I got some coffee. So I have some
coffee. Well let's just try with a shot of espresso. But yeah. We got some coffee and
we're ready to rumble. All I can think about is the Elden Ring DLC. I didn't do
much last night. To be honest, I didn't think I would beat Verlana yesterday. I
was just like oh let me just play a couple times before I go to bed. Blah blah blah.
And then fall asleep to some Elden Ring lore videos as one does. And then I beat her
in three tries and I'm like well I wish I caught this on stream. But okay. I didn't believe in myself
and I guess me not believing in myself and being comfy on my couch helped a lot. It was very nice
gaming from my couch because my couch is a lot comfier than my chair. Where did my cord go?
But I didn't really do anything other than beat her. As you guys saw it took me like 30 minutes
or maybe like an hour. And if you look at the timestamps on my tweets on my all account.
Then I went to go get some like farm some armor. So I got the which armor set did I get? I forget.
But then I realized Verlana's armor is better. So I was like never mind. Why did I just do this?
And then I was thinking okay do I need to do anything else before I go to
what's it called? Before I go to the Shadowkeep and trigger the NPC event.
And from what I gathered there's like one guy I might need to talk to. And the name is like
more something. I don't know if it's worth it. So I was going to ask you guys if it's worth it to go
like do that quest to get all those cookbooks. But I'm like I don't really know if I need the
foragers cookbooks. Are they like necessary? As your impactive blades got bleed a roof like five
hits nice. Bring my couch over. I could turn my couch around. I'm not even joking actually.
I'm not going to do that though. I would take a lot of strength and effort and I'm I'm too weak.
I'm not too weak but it would just cause me pain in the long run.
Let me hop over here.
Come on down. And um let me oh it's already connected. Perfect.
That's my cat. That's Boomi. He's having the time of his life.
Where's the chat? I just totally got rid of you guys. Not necessary. Okay I thought it wasn't
necessary. So yeah um I won't be like one speaky today. My voice isn't squeaky or high so sometimes
I just wake up like that. I don't want to tell you. Let's check it. There's some really weird
audio noise in the background. Oh hold on I think I know what that is. I accidentally unplugged my
go XLR so it probably is not behaving. Hold on let me restart.
Does that sound a little bit better?
Manelio?
Is it much better? Okay cool. Yeah so I accidentally kicked my thing before I started and I just
plugged it back in. I was like oh that'll be fine. No I forget I always have to restart the
go XLR app. But good morning. Hi. Let me tweet that I am live.
Hi. I'm playing the DLC again and I accidentally
be Renala off stream. I guess I don't know my own skills with a Z.
And then let's do an arm flex emoji.
That's a mechanical arm. Um flex. If I search flex I don't want to dig through the emoji list.
Okay and then we'll do a little blowing smoke from the nose face.
And then I'll add my lovely thumbnail that took me five minutes to do. Do you like how I just copied
the PNG from the wiki for Elden Ring for this the star sword thingy? That's all I did.
Um again I didn't really have a lot to do this morning so I'm like I just want to play Elden
Ring man. I don't know what to tell you. I just want to play Elden Ring all the time. It does look
like a wand. It does look like a wand. You're not wrong. Um didn't see the thumbnail. I don't know
whatever. That's fine. The thumbnail is not that crazy. Um somebody claimed the last video
which I thought was dumb. They claimed it for the Elden Ring music and I'm like come on bro.
And then they claimed um what else did they claim? They claimed another video of mine.
I'm like I'm gonna fight you bro. Hello hi. Can you keep writing over the thumbnail every time
yeah actually I'm thinking I'll do that. That's why I just added on to it. I might just change
the weapon if I change weapons. Um but I didn't get far. I literally just beat Rolanna and then
I got her and then I got another set of armor and then I was I was gonna play and do that guys
um quest line but then I saw how depressing it was and I decided I didn't really want to talk to
him at all. Um and then I wanted to ask you guys if it's worth it to do Moore's quest line for his
cookbooks um it's not claimable. They just they just do the the elder ever building gorilla thumbnail
yep. Um so literally we're just gonna go to the Shadowkeep and hope for the best. Um yeah I spoiled
like his end game uh dialogue for myself and I was like oh that's depressing. Damn son um I got my chai
oh let's get ready to rumble. Hold on I'm even trokus first I can't think my mom's next to me.
What are you doing for me? I don't know what my my son is doing. He's been he like I like came home
from seeing my mom and I was like hi for me and he was like like all happy and stuff and I went to pet
him and he just bit me and I'm like come on and now he's just spazzing out behind me so I think he
just wants to play um and then Reina's just watching him she's just sitting and staring at him freak
out in his little tunnel that you can hear it's crinkling in the background. No but it's true I
literally go and he like I went to pet him he was like roll him around all happy and I pet him on
the head and he just turns around and goes ah and I'm like brother oh hi Reina um let me stretch out
let's lean back a little. It's typical cat behavior it was a love nimble yeah no he was he was playing
I know he was playing I know it wasn't malicious I just thought it was funny he just wants to play
he's like a mouthy puppy Reina Reina's staring at me intensely and her mouth is open
she has like a doopy face oh my god what the fuck lady holy did you hear that she just slammed
herself on my desk she where did you even come from she was on my right side then she jumped
up for my left a second later how did that even happen
gee that just like jump scared me I didn't anticipate that hold on let me make my character
bigger so when I lean back it's like not too crazy okay now she's just purring on me I don't know
what is what's up what's up with you Reina anytime I think like Reina thinks that like every time I'm
at my desk it's like snuggled time because she like insists on like anytime I'm at my desk
she has to be on my lap she has to or she gets very like I don't even know now she's purring on my
ma'am can you lay down if you're gonna come hang out you have to lay down you can't just stand on me
you're standing with a full weight of yourself on my boob
let's check on my tomagotchi I haven't checked on it because I couldn't find it is it dead
what do you think Reina it's dead
I couldn't find my tomagotchi it was in the couch
he's dead
why isn't the thing working that's weird
they lived a long life guys I mean hold on I don't know why the sound isn't working
thank you for the don't know hold on I couldn't hear it what is
oh my sometimes I just have to switch the thing
what is happening I can't hear it because of the fucking BGM is going I don't know
boomi I blame you one more for the pile of bodies and Reina is all over me and I can't
move around and I have to like be in a comfortable position so she doesn't fall off my fucking lap
oh my god help please
see who makes three tiny coffins for the dead tomagotchis oh my god oh yeah and then at some
point before I end you're gonna help me with my schedule and I know my manager's gonna message
me about it and be like why haven't you done it yet no it'd be like because I'm mentally ill
forget why isn't this oh
but you guys still can't hear it
oh my god why is my desktop audio not working
oh what the heck Reina
on my desk I think she did she because she smacked my goxlr I don't okay let me restart it again
I'm gonna sound like shit for a second
oh
hail
why can't
why is this happening why can I have like a please like just like a scuffery stream can I
please have a scuffery stream like that's all I want
so
brother please
there we go
it's also super quiet for me too I don't know why that was doing that
but yeah I have Rolana's armor
I feel pretty cool I'm not gonna lie like
oh my god my headphones are stuck
where are they stuck on I just joked on my own spit
Reina don't bite it
okay
and you pick my wedge
you might hear some people working on stuff in the background because there's like
yard work going on in my building but anyways let's do this for the effect get him out of the frame
though boom I look pretty neat
posing for the photo drip immaculate you miss noodle she be miss tree be too bad but I like
how she has like crescent moons on her helmet um but it's nice and I also got boobas and I also
have a really long hair I don't know why they do that because like it's not part of her helmet
like that's her actual hair isn't it have you tried her sword I have not actually I've not tried
her swords I didn't I didn't get around to doing that oh I thought it would be over here
I need 12 13
um strength
so I I'm really just cosplaying as her right now oh she goes into different stances that's pretty cool
it'd probably be pretty sick because I know she can do like fire and shit um what is even my
my strength is at 12 I kind of want to bump it up to 13 just so I can use these at some point
if I two hands
I can't two hand swords that I already have out like I don't I don't think you can do that I don't
think you could two hand swords that you already I don't well now I'll be able to use it I didn't
mean to press that but
just kidding I still can't what the fuck why am I to only have one sword out
there we go
I wish I could fucking jump around like she does
I need a little bit of faith
wait what which faith do I have 11 because you gotta have oh yeah I need 16 faith oh
never mind well I'll I can always respect if I really really want to use those but
doesn't matter I have I have um well
I got the starline sword it's still pretty sick uh it was probably going to go in two hand this
and just be that bitch you know hello hi uh but yeah so let's get the show on the road
let's go to the shadow keep baby let me come let me bring you a little bit closer
hi how are you doing are you having a good morning and you wake up and do what you needed
to do and take care of yourself I hope you did I hope you took care of what you needed to take
care of before you are watching me or if you are watching me you are taking care of what you
need to take care of and not you are being productive and you're not just loving like I was
when I was a love yesterday okay all right you promise
you say I sound like that star
a day day get out of my laboratory a day day
a night night
trying to work okay I'll try not to be so distracting
sorry I sound a bit like glue minions we must steal the moon
no if I say girl she's a little girl girl when I sound like glue
I'm like the the famas
you haven't done a damn thing well put me on in the background and do your damn thing
do your dance on a thing you would do you know you're allowed to see okay um I'm the map I'm the
map I'm the map oh I don't have any graces over here is there a grace over here I'm pretty sure
there is isn't there oh wait I need to put that oh I don't have my oh it's a get up I don't want to
get out of my chair the bun speaker I don't know what you're talking about
again when I'm in a good mood my voice goes higher
I see now all the weenies all the weenies
okay
okay let me find that youtube video that I was using yesterday for the scuttle
scott man I wish you guys could see me I'm like literally wrapped up in a blanket like how it
was yesterday now my legs are cold because it's a small blanket um let's see the library
where where is I watch so many fucking videos on Elden Ring I'll hear this
hold on
oh hold on let me preface guys there's not a male in my house it's me watching a youtube video of
my cat's freaking out of me trying to find this frags okay all right
if you want to watch the video his name is rage gaming videos I don't know what everybody's like
freaking Scottish or like European that plays Elden Ring because every video I watch for like
like help it's always like a Scottish dude but it's never the same guy and I'm just really confused by
that is that a hiss no that was them moving a piece of cardboard around that I gave to them
to play with because cats just like the stupidest things to play with um but please don't attack me
okay please don't hurt me just listening to a video okay I know you guys don't care but I just
like me me
trigger
calm
oh fuck there's a boss
okay pause bro pause you're going so fast
are we the type of YouTube friends that don't like males here males are gross
talk to her disgusting males not in my christian minecraft stream not in my christian elen ring stream
we v alert do not collab with such heathens they are below me as a race no they're not a race
as a gender i'm a misandrist no i'm not that's a lie
okay
based she be based you're a male disgusting i only want have females watching me we are an elite
amazonian force good morning my face is 99 my face my fan base is 99 women okay
no i've already talked about this on the stream before i've collabed in my pl one time um with guys
because i was bullied into it because people said i was a horrible person if i didn't do it
and i regretted it afterwards because they kept making uh grape juice jokes and inappropriate
derogatory statements and i never ever wanted to do that ever again i'm just good
i am good like i got enough of that when i used to play cs go and and it wasn't like in lobbies
i just i was i'm good i'm good that won't present me uh so boys i'm sorry i know i'm high demand
but you're never gonna collab with me i'm sorry i'm not sorry but you know
read between the lines
i know i saw i saw clips from it and let me tell you right now
i i asked i asked them if we could be in it by the way but then i really i didn't know who
was in it all i saw that um there was a couple people in it that like girls and i'm like oh i
want to hang out with them and then i saw that there were other people in it and i was like no
and then i saw clips from what had happened and i was like this is what i mean like why would
you put yourself in that position because people are going to one like fan bases are gonna freak out
two some vtuber male vtubers know that the type of like if you're like a gfe vtuber whatever
you they're going to push your buttons and do shit on purpose yeah male is a race um
let's say let's say i was let's say i was in there and i was put in the same position
with the people that you guys all know what i'm fucking talking about i would have broken
characters so quick and i would have told them to shut the fuck up and do not fucking fuck with me
bro or i will end you i'm like i the disrespect from some of the people in that server and in the
in the in the words of roleplay you guys can't see i'm doing air quotes i'm sorry i'm raging right
now it pissed me the fuck off it pissed me the fuck off so bad
like i was i was like you literally just said this to her excuse me excuse you
what are you daft bro are you fucking daft are you did you what you dropped on the head as a child
um honestly i hope that somebody makes an all-female one because i would be in on that so
bad you guys know i love to improv and i love to roleplay uh i'm gonna go off because i was just
like i'm just personally mad that people were put into a situation that they shouldn't have been
put in and they're honestly i know those people who like the person the vtuber who was targeted was a
sweet person and now like i just feel bad for everybody in that server like i just i know and
i know that wasn't the server owner's intention at all
like i know they wanted a nice environment but so there's always someone that has to ruin it
you know and sometimes i'm happy
that we don't get invited to things because everybody thinks we're whores because we are
affectionate but they think we're like doing stuff on like fansly with men and i'm like
there's only my cat here he's a boy no that's disgusting nobody else is in my house um
but no don't bother looking it up i'm just i just saw it this morning when i was like
roman on twitter and i just got really pissed like i'm sorry like i'm going off right now
i'll probably cut this from the vod because i don't but i was i was honestly so fucking pissed off
like i was yeah no shame don't cause awesome content i was generally livid
and i have not gotten like that mad in a while watching that
like i have never like that i don't like like this is like it's just like that person
should apologize to them because you could you shouldn't you shouldn't um
like frame it and like oh it's role play no like you can be a respectful role player
i've never even done gta role play but i'm like that people like and i know probably some servers
are toxic like that but like come on you know um and mind you i also just feel bad for that vtuber
because i think like of course you have a brand and when you don't when you do something that's
like doesn't align with that brand but you like you're sacrificing the happiness of your fan base
for your own happiness it's a it's a fine line um and i know that that person probably just wanted
to stream and just have fun and play with their friends and then people have to ruin it for other
people so i honestly don't really blame that vtuber at all for just wanting to hang out uh or the
people that are normally labeled as like gfee to be in that server because they probably just
wanted to stay amongst themselves and just hang out and then people have to come and ruin it and
that just sucks so honestly i hope i hope someone out there makes a female only one i'm just saying
because like sometimes it can just be really toxic um and or as you can see that like the
minecraft server was a success the mario kart tournament was a success do you know what the
commonality of that was huh oh no males and don't get me wrong not all male vtubers are like that
like they're not like uh there are some that are actually entertaining and i don't watch them but
i know that there's some out there that are actually entertaining um and that are probably
good at what they do and they're just like you know one of the boys and respectful in a bro
that's great um but there's people who just take stuff too far and push buttons and it's just rude
i think that was very disrespectful i'm so i don't mean to go off but like i like
it yeah it's just i'm sorry i'm sorry
because like i want to role play so bad that'd be so fun like that's why i before i even saw
who was in there i was like can we please do this can we please and then my manager just
was like actually this is house this is who was also in there and i'm like yo ain't never mind
sorry jk no thank you
yeah like i've watched um uh uo to owo uo uo labs is the thing they rebranded yeah
and they helped me out in my pl they would they they rated me um during one of my uh
during my birthday donathon as my my pl and they're they they're interesting they actually
have interesting content i like watching people blow shit up that's fun the five nights at freddy
thing they just did that's cool the other shit that other people do not cool not cool and that's
why i like nova so much because she's like the female version of him um my chat's frozen again
what is new what's new there nothing's new oops i accidentally closed the game don't worry about
it um let me refresh it let's see if that fixes it um mind you i'm not like i'm very aware of
my fan base and what they want and they don't want so like you guys don't have to worry about that for
me um yeah nova yeah nova e she's she's chill she's cool she she made she rigged me spitting
on my spitting on her audience and that was pretty awesome it was pretty awesome and that's
when like when i first came out and she did that and i was like oh my god you're so cool for that
thank you i'm a very appreciative of of v4 mariah because they they actually like hang out with us
and like us otherwise everybody else is just like east degenerates and i'm like that's fine
you're entitled to but that's type of content we make i don't blame you at all um if people are
uncomfortable with it i'm not gonna force them to like me force them to hang out with me you know
like why the fuck would i do that uh i've come to terms with that before i was just like oh i need
everyone to like me how am i no it's not like they don't like me they just don't like what i
do and just like my view of male vtubers they're fine i just don't like what they do
no it's like there's nothing wrong with being a prude like there's nothing like if your brand is
being say so obviously you're not going to want to interact with a non-say so vtuber that's totally
acceptable in my opinion um carol terpheria um you know we just started it's only like
we're finally we finally almost at three months you know it's like we just started people were
like realizing like six months how chill we are so oh yeah yeah yeah no i don't want to i don't
want to explain i'm just i'm just explaining my my uh my my thought process
i'm just explaining my thought process to you guys what she means not say so honestly i will tell
you some of the clip and i've said this before some of the clips i see of a say so vtubers doing
stuff i'm like yo you're crazy to me i just swear a lot oh my boomy stop chasing reina hey it's
because i had coffee reina why are you digging she's just randomly digging please don't shit there
okay no you're not you're just you're just you're just making a little mess that's fine boomy do you
hold on let me get boomy a toy so he leaves her alone what are you doing mr i'm gonna get that
you like come here is this what you want
is this what you want mr oh is it your favorite toy is it a spring go get it
please don't lose it too i'll be very mad if you lose it under the fridge again
um and yeah like obviously i have my moments and stuff where i say like saucy things but i
only do it to get a reaction out of you guys because your reactions are funny um sometimes you
gotta get the clown make up out yeah facts
but yeah don't don't don't twist it and um think that i'm like hating on say so vtubers no i used
to be a say so vtuber before i joined violer so like i'm not gonna that'll just be a fucking
hypocritical of me um but yeah sorry for the rant i was just again that just really bothered me
this morning uh yeah why is this why is my thing not centered hello that was weird
it's how so weird it was like just off to the side all right so we're there let's ride up
rena i'm sorry you can't hop on my lap right now
welcome welcome the member got it you're a hater twist it twist twist every word i say i dare you
was that a fun i think i had a really fun stream in uh yesterday no rena you i'm sorry
you can't be on my lap right now i can't snuggle i snuggled with you this morning
no rena please i love you so much but i can't
hello hello have you tried rilana's boss i said but uh i literally the beginning of stream was
trying to use it and i couldn't use it because i don't have enough strength or faith oh what's
that oh wow that was useful but i've always wanted a black pyre fly what's over there
i can't use it because i'm agroed what's over here did i go over here i don't think i did
maybe i did maybe i didn't we'll find out damn this bro is chasing my ass down i can hear him
uh i think i did already come here
no i didn't yes i did i did that's right i remember i picked up something over here
and i was like i think i forgot something do you think it's a burg
um sorry sometimes i'll just say stuff that reminds me of something else out loud without a filter
you like shebred shebred sounds like i'm just a female bread like a she-cat
i'm a shebred i get bread i mean no i mean like i get bread like money guys
not fuck me no not like stop talking sheby stop just shut up wait what's in the tent
i want what's in i can't get what's in the tent never mind
i should play i am what ain't bread i don't
hello
somewhere a great rune has broken
and so too has a powerful charm
i don't quite understand that because i know you just you break michela's
charm over people um
and i don't get why approaching the shadow keep does that to be honest with you i can't see shit
you
michela's discarded oh okay so when he discards his rune because he's shedding his his body to be cut
to attain godhood
to clint i still don't know america sin was but go off this um
um
all right so apparently we got a boss fight in here
yeah you're following michela in real time and dlc's moving around as you are that's pretty neat
actually like you progress time and like again elton ring is so unique and i love it so much
because of how they integrate gameplay mechanics into the actual lore like this is literally a whole
game about why you keep coming back to life after you die as a player in a game like that's
doubt like when i realized that when the first came out that honestly boggled my mind and i'm
like why hasn't anybody really done that before would be cool if i knew the lore well let me
tell you there are 3 13 hour 12 hour videos by smoke town that you can watch i haven't watched
those yet because i i just i can't lock in um i know dark souls one has like a the same thing
because i all from soft games like work oh come on i should have um
scratching my nose
hey can you like give me a second actually let me die by the beginning in front of the room so
i can grab my runes so this is a bigger version of the hippo i fought earlier good thing i already
know the moveset take a sip of my i have i'm drinking uh the apple crisp chai
with a shot of espresso which is why i'm fucking and bugging out right now
um with a shot of espresso from star basil fo shizzle my nizzle um oh my god she be said
no relax okay all right let me just okay
no
no where am i oh my god you're already gonna kill me it's so big this arena sucks
yeah you get them i'm gonna just keep healing over here no reason oh
wow you're just literally a bigger version of the other one and i still suck
all right this might take a while
starbies instead of dunking i know america runs on dunking but i just simply do not
one because the the dunking that i used to frequent because it was in the near the near the um
store i used to work at just absolutely fucking sucked so i just i i i just i'll drink
dunks like don't get me wrong don't get me wrong kid i'll drink some dunks don't don't get a twisted
kid i'll tell you that much um my friend also used to work at dunka donuts you know everything
that they told me about that place was terrifying uh dingalingaling batman o ring
okay charges and then i jump away jump away fuck i was too early in my jump and i'm almost dead
quick heal quick run away
quick fuck him up quick
fuck him up quick jump away quick heal quick heal quick quick get bitten
quick get destroyed quick heal quick almost die again quick die
dunking is sacred ground you you aren't wrong
it's like a dunk every dunks every two miles it's like a it's like tim hortons for canadiens
i i
guys uh i might might why why do you get aggro all the way over there i just oh my god
all right please just let me live my life
yeah grab them instead jesus christ is there a way to like jump up here i know lightening would
probably be effective um what are you doing brother
i can't even all right i might have to like long range no but he even though he like he's
even though he's slow he's so fast
gregs for britain i thought it was like a test goes testes
teca tech can i who can i summon for this fight i just want to see
just like lita come back or like freya
i talked to freya i'm surprised i'm pretty sure freya helps with this fight maybe not
maybe i'm just delusional
i'm thinking that i should honestly i can't summon yet i'm thinking that i should honestly um
i am pressing b i am pressing b motherfucker oh my god
i wasn't paying attention to my fucking hill
she bt coffee what
freya and horns all but the it doesn't really matter because again like you guys said it um
can i like actually like rune
my eye is twitching because i'm irritated or i need oxygen i don't know what it means
oh thank you jesus christ your range is ridiculous get him get his ass i'm i have him distracted
how am i i'm not hitting him
what is happening here i don't i'm a little confused i was a swing in my sword for no reason
oh
oh at least me stepping out of the way i can't fucking see this is a terrible arena
oh my god actually just like kill me kill me
just do it just end my suffering at least you don't kick backwards because that's
i can't you why how are you so big what oh i forgot there's a second phase
oh fuck i totally forgot you turned into a fucking porcupine
oh my god that's my summon dead am i dead
no what is this why are you the ancestral beast spirit
oh
i i was past you i was literally i'm pointing you can't see but i was literally past him
i don't
fuck this bitch boomie what are you doing i hear you doing something behind me i just don't know what
it is what is this avatar the last airbender he's a hippo hippo creep coupon okay i'm not
going to summon i'll say the summon for the second half fuck me if i last that long that's a great
question
hi hi hi hi hi hi hi hi hi here's my samurai
you just hear boomie honk in the background what are you doing
oh you're playing with your toy okay good boy who fed this thing why he's so big
uh i'm thinking what i should be doing is his mate should be casting on him
okay don't roll into his mouth that's that's a little word of advice from me uh not recommending it
where is he oh
you
i rolled i rolled
i i i i i rolled to the side it just doesn't like me
i was in the middle of healing i'm gonna keep healing oh thank god i'm on the ground
thanks thanks for giving me a chance i can i please get out of this fucking corner
i uh why this is like fighting the fucking fire giant in this arena i swear to god i'm just
gonna get rolled on
my it's that crazy looking hippo again it's outside hello good morning
good morning
uh what am i doing i'm thinking sorry to crack my neck
why aren't there summon signs popping up am i stupid like did i not talk enough to
freya and horn sent brother
can i use these giant staff like what are these even before
um it looks like grandma
go talk to them again at our charm is broken okay let's do a little
i'm doing all right you know just you know wake up you know what i like to do in the morning
when i wake up i like to rage at a game that's what i like to uh where you guys at okay that's
lita all the guys i'll just talk to you again
you are a bad shit crazy you can't wait to kill your boyfriend later um there you are
didn't see you pass the fucking sheep
what remains there to be said
nice even now
you are no well i was never really your ally i look at my sword is this close to your fucking face
all right sick uh i don't know where forest freya she over here let's just have a little chatty chat
i can't hate on lita too much because she helped me during the uh ronalda ralana whatever the
fuck her name is fight you're hello big boss lady hey good if you happen to see lady ledger
crazy i just saw her striking out on my own oh don't worry i've no mind to cross any of you
i love your voice actress
okay there's something that i must know
what do you intend to look into
uh yes the gay lovers here the vow shall be honored i am a red man i must know the nature
understandable what is the nature of the bow uh can we talk to folie i'll talk to sir unspuck
what's his what's his uh my voice actress oh crazy she's a piece of shit let me tell you
um let's talk to everybody actually i kind of i'm kind of curious
okay oh you're that fucking dude i'm not talking wait oh actually i'll talk to you
i can still buy shit from you oh nothing that i need sick
no
you're aging faculties
and folly is better left forgotten haunt me once again i'm so sorry
i look like i'm about to creep up and hit him to free lord moe from his enchantment i challenge
to tender micah oh i have my own heart rather artfully stolen yeah he's she's shit for that
it's okay he's he's a hot twink even an empyrean would be within reach of my blade
i think i've been more mistaken yeah micah the kind is a monster you're not fucking wrong he's
a piece of shit he wields love to strive clean in the hearts of men and there's nothing more terrifying
nothing more terrifying than a twink with magic love powers i'll tell you that much
rage she be legends play now use code she be
i'll talk to dain i know dain doesn't you like fight him if you do the uh simp the the
what's it called if you like flip him off an emote form
hey i need me to do that i just want to talk to you should i fight him
should i do the little thingy and fight him
okay brothers yeah it's funny because they're also brothers
george rm are insured does live in breeding fight him okay i'll fight him uh if i could
eat one culture for the rest of my life what would it be Haitian food because i'm Haitian
although you know i do like Italian food and uh asian like i would probably do like
tie ties pretty nice um so that's a hard question uh
what how do i do the gesture i never did gestures because i never did pvp
i don't mean to talk to you i'm trying to press another button i'm pressing the wrong one
let's let's no
i'm so you know how it says x remove so i'm using a playstation five controller so x is down there
but no it's a to use i forget if i like rotate my freaking controller a certain way it'll do the
gesture which is the weirdest thing to me okay can i only do the gestures here
can i no i want to remove it
which one was it
this one
where the fuck he's fucking teleported all the way over there
why because you get the martial arts from him that's right
i'm so sorry
i just killed a man
i just straight up killed a man
now i can have a cool hat that's pretty nice
i think it's cool they added like martial arts in this
touch me pop a squat
uh who else let's risk the lia
we can talk to horn sent brother
guys my chat breaks every 15 minutes just
actually you know what let me see if i can find another youtube chat
so
it looks really gross
yeah
all these fonts look the same i don't understand
so
farewell brothers you're gone
you
yep
how long will this is so now you guys can just take up my whole screen
there you go
just kidding i thought your internet would help
we are so back
so back bros
i should probably change the size
so
damn this is so fucking huge
this is so fucking huge don't do long sentences it's not allowed no no more long sentences
how the fuck
do i make you guys smaller
i forget what the size i used before was
oh
you guys disappeared i'm so sorry
i don't know what just happened
what if i do
where the it's gone
the whole thing just fucking left
all right well let's try this again let's remove that
no that's not right
fabulous
all right uh i think that looks good
is that does that look fine
does that look
does that look good
i'm kidding uh no i just need to change the width
just make the width like i don't know
huh what are you doing
what are you idiots doing
i'm trying to make it so you're not cut off so much
my internet's okay today
can can you see that all right is it like blurry
i'm an hour behind on my own pod okay that looks fine
behave just pickable fools behave i can't do my same voice
all right
what is wrong with you
it's funny because that shows up on that the chat but doesn't show up in the actual chat
on youtube that giant we i don't know if one of my my mods nuked him but it still shows up
that's very interesting
yeah it didn't show up i wonder if it like youtube just auto nuked it somebody do it again
i'm curious
okay just doesn't youtube just doesn't like that guy in particular
no i'm scarred you all just get banned no i'm kidding um
i'm thinking
we poke him with a stick no i'm thinking we do lightning
tbh uh just because no fuck um
yeah
sure
is the hippo magic resistant
she really love all this fucking staff
she bit
oh i have my chat set for i think top
i didn't know that was a thing
are you guys saying justice for boomi
boomi's boomi i didn't say anything about boomi
weak to fire and lightning neutral of magic all right let's just do let's just do
let's just let's just how much what do i need for scaling for the lightning bottles faith
oh
was just two hand that uh what the hell where am i
oh that's right i was talking to the horn sent dude
these are not the horn sent dude where is he uh i mean the horn sent i didn't talk to grandma
where's grandma my blind where is she
oh she's all the way over there no i'm not going over there i wanted her opinion but now i don't
where is my boy oh here he is
granny went to eat
then to do the boss you guys are annoying
hi sweetie
oh
not really no
damn he fucked all of y'all
her sense
chasing you
oh you wait your love of sentry not not me i'm kind of his
well you could kill yourself with those sleep pots that you have
except i didn't do your thing properly
i don't think so i can't even do those or do i do them later
you
ate trina i love trina trina trina is me she's a sleepy girl for real for real
oh my god i just took off my bra and i feel so freed
you're annoying but we are lovable you're annoying and breathable how about that
i'm gonna breed all of you
get bread get bread get bread uh okay so we have
freya you know let's do it it's fun it's fun with friends it's always funner with friends
can i okay
hey queen
waiting for mr. horn sent to show up
i don't like that he's just called horn sent i kind of wish he had an actual name
because like the horn sense the race so i don't it's so very weird to me that his name is just
horn sent like he doesn't have a name uh all right let's tango
let's let's i don't know i turned on my lamp let's tango why does this feel door feel bigger
let's party it's a party in the usa
damn it
can i
no please please i'm i'm trying okay well
so
oh i'm on the other side okay well
okay
oh i thought i rolled out of the way for that no
no
okay
why can't i repost him okay thank you
jeez
what
please don't
fucking
what the hell can you die
jeez i just i'm like what's happening here
that's pretty cool aspects of the crucible nifty
oh my god i'm like why can't i hit him
this is the weirdest hitbox despite being fucking huge
all right thanks queen let me just grab these so i don't have it showing up on my shit
what am i what's my thing pointing at
oh i don't know why i marked that didn't mean to
let's pop a squat
okay we got 60 vigor
made it look easy yeah but you didn't see me struggle the first like five minutes
i mean um 10 tries uh how do i get up here help
help how do i leave help
hey what's up
no such a thing is utterly inconceivable we have not been abandoned
mesmer is the son of queen marica
her grace would never abandon her own flesh and blood except she fucking did
i'm not needed um
um
boomie can you leave her alone what are you doing to my plant no
oh
That's a little bit better, look at that.
I want to stare at it so you can just follow it.
Oh yeah, Mesmer is going to be fun.
Mesmer is going to be a fucking joy.
This chair is hurting my butt lately.
I don't understand why.
What if I do this?
Ooh, comfy.
All right.
Okay, what if I put this behind me?
I knocked over my plant.
But I fixed it so it's fine.
Yeah, he's like, he like licked her fur in the wrong direction.
She's this wet spot on her.
I might have to brush her.
It's kind of funny looking.
She has like a cowlick except it's a boomy lick.
Let's put a flame resist talisman.
What is he, what is Mesmer weak to?
Cause I have the flame drake talisman three so I should be fine.
He's weak to fire.
Yeah.
He's weak to slash and frostbite.
I'm not really using sorceries right now so I might do that.
I don't need magic negation.
Oh, I got the blessed do talisman so I might grab that.
I don't even know what to say to you anymore.
I don't think I, do I have anything that does slash?
Okay, so my backhand blade might actually be helpful.
I can, I don't have a frost ass of war.
You said I need a magic wet blade for that, don't I?
I don't know why I don't have the magic wet blade.
Oh, I never grabbed it.
Sorry, I'm watching where that is.
Cause I went in that room, I just never fucking grabbed it.
Oh my god, I'm so dumb.
I've been, I like, I've been told that it seems like Mesmer gets weak in his second face.
That's why I kind of want to beat him as soon as possible before they fucking patch that.
Let's quickly go to the debate parlor in Ryokaria and go get that.
Wait, no, it's not in the debate parlor.
I think it's for lore reasons.
Is it over here?
Oh yeah, it is actually.
My eye is fucking twitching hardcore.
I don't know why my eye has been twitching lately.
It's my right eye.
I don't know why I never grabbed this.
Can you de-aggro me please?
How are they still aggroing me?
I'm literally.
The fact that I didn't kill you in one hit is actually kind of weird.
Oh yeah, I forgot there's a fucking maiden over here.
Awkward.
Oh wait, you're re-delighting.
Bitch.
Wow, if only I had this when I was fucking doing the duo.
Jesus Christ.
Time for crab.
I want crab legs.
Oh my god, crab legs would fucking slap.
Fuck up some crab legs.
Sorry.
This is just the poppins of my head.
I don't even know where I would get crab legs.
Hola!
Wait, can I raise my spear dash?
No, I don't have a ghost glove, Ward 6.
Hey.
Why do you?
I wish they would vary his thing.
Be like, oh, where you been?
What are you buying?
What are you selling?
I wish I had two backhand blades.
Actually, hold on.
Let's take a moment.
Slash Pierce.
I wish I had more faith.
Actually, no, he has...
I know that won't help his fire.
I don't have enough strength because then I would just throw it on the Nagakiva.
Dragon Hunter's Great Katana has Slash Pierce.
But I don't think I can...
I can't put an actual war on that.
I don't have enough faith.
I love the sides.
Hello.
I find your lack of faith disturbing.
No, I don't feel like respecking.
Never talked to Gideon.
I did briefly and I destroyed his entire room.
Hi, hi. Good morning.
Time.
Do you hear Boomi in the background?
He's just skating across my hardwood floor.
I don't know what he's doing.
I keep scrabbling in the background.
We just killed the hippo and I'm debating...
Well, I have...
I can just throw Frostbite on here.
I just like having these as lightning just because...
I like usually to have one weapon of every type that I can switch between.
That's what I did on my first playthrough for the open base game.
But I think I might just...
Frostbite...
No, I still haven't been to Bonnie Village.
Cotton Booms?
Why wouldn't it be Cotton Bombs?
It was right there and you totally missed that, brother.
I'm just thinking...
Don't I need more faith for Perfume Bottle?
I don't feel like respecking right now.
But I actually really want to use the Perfume Bottle because it's just a weird thing.
Because Bonnie Village is literally right here.
I just haven't gone or I've been...
No, I haven't been.
I came through...
Did I go down there?
Now I kind of feel like doing some more exploration before I move forward in the Shadowkeep.
I'll be honest with you.
The Frostbite has no faith.
It's intelligent.
Oh, let's go get it, boys.
I know Bonnie Village is over here.
I don't have any sites of grace.
Wait...
Is there a...
Is there a ring?
Not a ring.
Is there a spring thing?
No, that's right.
I had to run up.
There wasn't any spring thing.
But I can still probably go up this way, right?
And then go down.
He's moaning in the background.
There's a hole in the ground.
Let's do it.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
Go get it.
I don't know where the Perfumer Talisman is.
Where is it?
Tell me.
I'll grab that, too.
If you're just coming in, my Tamagotchi died.
Poggers.
You said where?
Base game.
Is it a perfume bottle?
Is that consecrated snow fields?
Because I didn't even lock them on top of the Giants.
I didn't...
I feel like it's over there.
I know there's a lot of ice magic over there,
and I did not get any of it.
Okay.
Into the Perfumer Ruins.
Again.
Yes, again.
There I go.
You can see how I didn't even bother with this area.
Where are the Perfumer Ruins?
No.
Did I go there?
Where are the Perfumer Ruins?
I forget.
It's over here.
No, that's the Windum Ruins.
It's over there.
It was pretty ugly.
It's probably like an 8 out of 10 ugly.
Left of that little lake.
Top?
Left of this little lake?
This one?
So it's over here?
Yes.
Alright, let's do it, boys.
How the hell do I get over there is the question.
Because again, I didn't unlock all the sites of Grace.
Oh wait, I can just go down.
I never use a perfume bottle, so I'm kind of excited.
So I can know what direction I'm going in.
Be careful of dragon.
Dragon, these balls.
Death.
How about I be careful of myself?
I need some juice.
I'm kind of thirsty.
Let's get the Talisman and then I'll...
I'm so sorry.
I just like to go off the beaten path.
Wait, are my ruins going to be up there?
Come here, bro.
The wolf is just looking at me.
They're just sitting there like, hey, what's going on?
Let me grab them.
I know it's only like not even 20k, but...
Don't mess with me, puppies.
There's a lot of golems.
Okay, so we did it that way.
And then we keep going down.
And then over there.
Go one.
That's right, I never fought land sacks over here.
You think she's weak against lightning?
Who was that?
Yippee.
I think so, five.
Let's grab this one here.
Where is she?
I don't even fucking see land sacks.
She's just fucking gone.
She's teleported away.
Boo, land sacks.
What's this ash for, I forget.
No, you bitch.
Sacred order?
I don't really hear about that.
There we are.
Okay, I'm just going to run around.
You guys got anything?
Oh fuck, I forgot you were here.
Can I pick this up?
No, these are just perfume bottles.
At least you guys aren't that damaging to me.
Remember last time that happened, I just fucking got got.
All right, where are you, Talisman?
Where is the entrance to the hole?
I like how there's a bunch of perfumers here.
Can I, can I please like, come on.
Ow, let me breathe.
Oh, that's, I don't, I think he's, oh my god.
I'm getting fire and shit all over me, there it is.
Torrent help.
Yep.
No, these are just perfume bottles, where is it?
I'm getting poisoned.
It's all take a moment.
It's under the floorboards, okay.
Sorry, there's poison fucking everywhere.
There we go.
Oh, Jesus.
I'm busy, don't hurt me.
Perfect, there we go.
I just teleport out of here.
Where are we going?
We are going to Bonnie Village.
What is the best way to get there?
You said there is a hole in the ground.
Oops, all poison.
Jackie Chan, I don't know who Shen Gong Wu is, I'm sorry.
I have another time at work.
Perfume Talisman in existence.
Yeah, because I was literally like, what the fuck are perfume?
I remember, I was like, what is the point of this?
I'm never going to use it.
Looky here, now I'm going to use it.
Now I'm going to use it real good.
Direct me.
I look sexy as hell.
I'll wait.
I'm going to get some juice while you guys tell me which direction to go in.
Follow the building is the hole in the center of the town.
The hole in one of the buildings.
What buildings?
Like the, hold on, let me turn.
Are these buildings?
These ones.
I got my honest kid's juice box here.
My strawberry peachy keen.
Great flavor.
Hello.
Follow the path.
All right, queen.
Yeah, the only back seating I allow is directions when it comes to when it comes to fucking course.
I like juice boxes and go go squeeze is awesome.
You guys don't, you guys don't know how to zoom or I really am.
I got to keep that haggler, you know, you can't all be zoomers and dealer.
Puppy.
Can't lock on puppy.
Puppy close to death.
Man close to death.
Can you stop digging?
Why are you so powerful?
He's got one shot of a guy with just living his life.
All right.
Follow the path.
There's not really a path per se.
Do you guys throw rock at me?
Oh, hole in the ground, hole in the ground.
Looking like a fool with a hole in the ground.
I found the hole in the ground.
Who are you?
How do I get down there?
I'm not going to use torrent because I'm probably going to beat my ass if I use torrent or bust my ass rather.
Why am I so powerful?
Yeah, you think we wouldn't have fucking...
We invented Capri Sun.
All right, Capri Sun is an American thing.
What is this?
This is Stratatone Stone Tellsman 4.
Oh, fascinating.
Who is crying so loud?
Let me put you out of your misery.
There must be somebody up there.
I just missed.
I can't really see.
I might have to use torrent.
I hate Kool-Aid.
Kool-Aid tastes gross.
But, Shibi, you're brown now.
Kool-Aid tastes fucking gross.
Okay.
I also...
Yeah, it just tastes disgusting to me.
Nobody was going to say it.
Yeah, but you're thinking it.
I just say what you guys are thinking out loud.
That's all I do.
I know what you guys think.
That's why I'm like...
You're like, Shibi, nobody even said that.
I'm like, yeah, but you're thinking it.
You know?
It was actually in the middle of typing it.
Yeah, whatever.
Kool's brown.
He was probably going to be like,
what are people?
It's our people's drink.
Capri Sun for bottles.
That's disgusting.
Shibi, stop trying to meet the hair.
What?
You're the racist.
You guys are all racist.
I have a racist fan base.
It's kind of disappointing.
Who is crying?
I want to kill you.
Too loud.
Make it stop.
Rada rada.
But you're one of the...
You're one of the good ones.
I hate you.
Do you feel better now as she falls to the ground?
Well, I tell you my friend.
Oh, no, guys, stop.
No, we...
Oh, my God.
They literally...
Everybody...
You guys are going to make people hate me
even more than they already do.
Shibi's fan base is racist.
They all admitted it on a stream.
Torrent, what the fuck are you doing?
I don't know how you're supposed to jump down here, genuinely.
I can't really see a lot of...
I'm going to fall and die from here.
Yeah, like, I don't...
This is fucking stupid.
I don't see how to jump down.
Shibi, you call this racist?
Because you guys are.
That doesn't mean I am.
The V-Tweeters will find a way to hate everything regardless.
You're not wrong.
Honestly, if you don't stream, I don't care about your opinion.
I'm kidding.
I'm feeling edgy this stream.
I'm feeling edgy.
I'm feeling disgruntled.
I'm feeling...
I'm feeling like causing problems.
I'm pressing backwards.
Can you turn around, Torrent?
I'm feeling 2016.
I'm feeling Turkey Tom with this one, boys.
I'm feeling Keemstar.
Oh my god.
How am I supposed to get down here?
Not feeling Keemstar.
I'm feeling a little leafy is here.
Should I hop on surf?
Should I hop on some CS GO surf?
Don't say his name in this chat.
Don't say the A name.
Shibi unhint.
Shibi unmasked.
The Shabari is off.
You know what that means.
I'm going back to my YouTube commentator days.
Did you know when I was in a call with I'm Alex
and Hyogen and Pyro that Hyogen called me the N word?
I was like very floored.
I was just solidly like, huh?
What?
Oh yeah.
By the way, if you're new here, hi.
My name is Shibi.
I used to work for Drama Alert.
I used to be a YouTube commentator.
Was this live?
No, no, no, no.
This was not live.
This was literally, this was literally, um, this was years ago.
Hi, my name is Shibi Cottonbum and Zoe Burger tried to scout me
for an e-girl fan thing.
Oh yeah, hard R.
I was like, what?
And then I left the call because I was pissed off.
I'll tell you right now, UK commentators are all fucking racist.
Hi, my name is Shibi Cottonbum.
I used to work with Celestia Vagan.
She's actually a very sweet person.
And she did a lot of stuff that ruined her mental health
and I feel very bad for her.
She's honestly very, very sweet.
Hi, my name is Shibi Cottonbum and it was really funny to watch
Zoe Burger become a Mormon woman.
Mmm.
Strawn, you wanted me to do a whole like YouTube short
about how I worked for Drama Alert and I'm like,
I'm good.
I don't want people to find me.
Shit.
Oh, maybe I'm supposed to land on that.
That makes sense.
Some crazy Shibi lore, yeah.
Hi, my name is Shibi Cottonbum and Colossal is crazy.
I'm actually a very funny human being.
Oh, yeah.
I already told you guys anything of reviews hit on me
when I went to a PAX and I was like, please go away.
Let's see here.
I feel like if I jump off, it's just not going to work.
I might have to look at a YouTube tutorial about this.
Can I give you the N-word pass?
No, you're fucking stupid.
Oh my God.
Mods, fucking kill him.
My mods are not here.
Mods, kill him.
Mods, rip off his nutsack and shove him down his throat.
If you guys ask me for the N-word pass,
I genuinely fucking hate you because that's just stupid.
Here's half a pass.
No, you're fucking an idiot.
Even if you're just beaming, it's just annoying.
My name is Shibi Cottonbum and this is Jackass.
I don't know how to get down here.
I generally don't understand.
Why did they do this?
Poor level design.
Give me a fucking rock.
Am I right in thinking that I'm supposed to jump on this?
Okay, I was right.
All right, cool.
Watch something just kill me.
Oh, get away.
Get away.
Ow, ow, ow.
I don't know what this is.
What?
Please don't kill me.
I'm really busy this day.
Thank you.
Thank you, Mod.
I'm feeling very toxic today.
I feel like airing out my grievances against people.
Stop crying, you fucking baby.
Why are there just random candles here?
Here's a little bit of light, so it's not completely dark for you.
Yeah, only I can be toxic.
You guys can't be toxic if I'm toxic.
There can only be one toxic person.
It's either me or Chat, and I'm toxic right now.
What are you talking about, Mari?
Where did you come from?
Hello, welcome to Herrim Emotes.
I will never touch League.
You can pay me.
I'll take 100k for League.
100k and I'll play League.
I'm never fucking playing League.
Well, I was gonna say a million,
but I want actually someone to pay me 100k
because that seems a little bit more viable.
Look at all these jars.
I feel like I should be able to enter
some of these buildings, but...
Oh, is it a well?
Oh, that's where I just came out of,
because I'm an idiot.
Oh, I'm surprised there's no, like,
evil jars in here trying to lock on to anything.
Oh, there we are.
That's not 100k, that's a dollar.
But thank you for the dollar.
Hey, y'all.
I shouldn't even bother, like,
electric doesn't bother any of these dudes.
Ow!
That's not very cash money of you.
I can't get up.
Yeah, meet me down here. Meet me down here.
Meet me down here.
Not resin.
He's a furry.
With all this information, people are going to hunt me down
and try to find my very disapeal.
Trust me, there is nothing of interest there.
I was literally...
I was a literal who
who just happened to know a network really well.
I was, but that was my V-Tweeter error.
I made, like, three videos,
and they're all gone and deleted.
Aw.
I was a literal who and I flew under the radar.
Hey.
I just want to grab stuff.
What are you doing?
Got a butchering knife.
Where's the... I wonder where the whip is.
Let's be further down.
Why is everybody crying?
Pussies. Stop crying.
Oh, you got shoved into a jar, so what?
Quite harder.
Did I get raided? Who are you?
Who is this dude?
I can't even lock on.
Oh, it's a greater potentate.
Good thing you have terrible fucking stance.
Too bad I am also getting just stance broken.
How much fucking stamina do you have, brother?
You're just wearing...
You're just not wearing any clothes.
You're just wearing the caterpillar hood.
Good morning. Hello.
Why should the vaude be unlisted?
Why should I unlist the vaude?
I don't care. I'm going to speak my fucking truth.
Hate everybody.
I also should have been hating all of those people because they were all older than me.
She be toxic, bum.
It sounds like I just haven't washed my ass.
I washed my ass this morning when I took a shower.
But yeah, I never assumed that my girl is will stay up or not.
I'll just cut the whole first half of this vaude
because it's not like I did anything.
There's yellow paint here.
I thought this was...
Resident Evil.
Why are you fucking crying?
Oh, did that Diagro?
He just like wiped his sword and then it was like, never mind.
I came over here to fight you.
Come on.
Come on, bitch.
Oh, I forgot that it sucks health.
I don't...
I don't like that.
Oh.
The AI for you is really good.
I won't lie.
The dodging was very impressive.
I don't get anything for that.
That's fucking stupid.
All right.
Let's go this way.
Wait, no, I can't.
Can I?
Why can I summon my ashes here?
I don't...
Can I just jump over with Torrent?
Yes, I can.
I saw something in the ravine though, so I'm kind of interested,
but since I don't know how to get back up yet,
I'll wait. Oh, there is a bunch of these dudes.
I'm just going to run away from you then.
Yippee.
Farewell.
It'd be funny if a dragon just totally demolished
this bridge and I fell to my death.
Now he will cross the bridge.
He will cross the bridge.
Archive broves are just going to be like,
she be stopped deleting streams.
Well, it's a gorilla.
Whipping hut.
This is where I take care of him.
Where...
Where is said perfume bottles, by the way?
Can you guys tell me that while I run over
and grab this grace? Thank you kindly.
Whipping hut, juniors!
Please, hello?
Help.
Where is it?
Tell me.
Where is the perfume frost bottle?
Type faster!
Faster, faster, faster!
Type!
Type faster!
He just stood up.
Oh, it's a horn sent.
For pity's sake,
your place is in the jar.
Nice, sainthood itself awaits you
within.
For shamans like you, this is your lot.
Life, where you accorded for this alone.
I actually hate the horn sent.
I'm not going to lie for just shoving people into jars.
It's sainthood.
You are one with the world and the crucible.
That's why I'm like,
Micaela, you're even more of a piece of shit.
I know America fucked up.
Everything went wrong when she showed up,
but like, you know.
Can I open a map?
My guess is near Bonnie Village.
No fucking way, bro.
Where's the jail?
It's not even showing the jail on the map.
Where the fuck is the jail?
Well,
it's the red stuff in the bottom left over here.
That's a tree.
It's south of Bonnie Village.
Oh man, the bottles were not in Bonnie.
I don't know where all the flowers were.
Flowers?
What flowers?
I didn't see any fucking flowers.
All the way left?
Do you mean in the Cerulean Coast?
Guys, I'm asking where that frostbite...
You guys told me that the Bonnie...
It was near the Bonnie Village, the frostbite bottle.
Why did you... Who was talking about Bonnie Village then?
I'm gonna fucking end your life.
In Elden Ring.
I don't know.
I don't even see the Bonnie Jail, anyways.
Usually...
It shows up as a little dot, so I'm surprised they don't see it.
Am I just fucking blind?
Blue flowers with red thorns. Where's that from? I can't ever get
Yeah, I'm gonna elde your ring. Um
Limiters jails between in the grave site plane
Is it like there? I don't know my eye is twitching because I'm irritated
Ever jails are different. Oh dots are ever jails. Okay
It's north slightly where my court, okay, I'm gonna stay right here
Up and to the left slightly
It's in this crack of the over here here
Over here. Yes. Alrighty boys
Let's fucking zoom
In that general region, okay
I can't whistle usually that was impressive. Um
What am I doing?
I want crab legs so bad. Where can I even get crab legs?
Just do a mukbang of crab legs. How do you get that from car-
Oh
Joe's crab shack no there used to be one uh and it closed
So I have to
They got replaced with something else. Um
The last time was there. I was crying to my dad
Because you get remind remember so I I grew up a very christian
religious girl
Very christian very religious
I had no sexual inkling in me whatsoever
The last time I was at a joe's crab shack. I was crying to my dad
Because my friend had just told me
That she sucked a boy's pee pee
And I and she and then I was scared she was gonna get x communicated and I didn't know what to do
I
Was like
That was the last time I was at a joe's crab shack
It's funny
I
Over here
Kinkiest once married, I don't know how am I supposed to know that I am not married
Unless we get married
I will now think
And it was funny because she did get x communicated and I wasn't allowed to talk to her
What
And then I I talked to her like
Like a year ago
Actually, maybe less than a year ago
Go find a key in cave. What fucking key how
Oh, there's nowhere else to go. Is there another entrance that I did not see?
Um
And we met up and I'm like, oh, how oh there is uh, I'm fucking blind. I was
We're like, oh, how do people find out because I told my dad
And my dad told
um
My my friend's parents because she said if she was gonna kill herself
Over it and hindsight, it's fucking stupid. Um
Like she thought she had committed this great sin
And so I talked to her like a year ago and she's like married with a kid now and I'm like, this is weird
And that person had apparently uh, not the same guy she he had ruined her life though like she
Didn't talk to her parents for years because of that
That's wild she's a snitch
If your friend says she's gonna kill herself because she sucked up a guy's pee pee at age 15
Then I'm gonna and you don't know what to do
And you're like me who is so so so socially inept and didn't know how the world really worked
Then yeah, I guess that makes me a snitch
Oh
What the fuck are you?
Oh guys, what the hell is that?
What the fuck is this?
Oh, you're actually kind of pretty
No
Never mind I take this back. I didn't think you would be able to grab me
Same kind of innocence when you slap on me out of your mom's hand when she was in the car because you heard her
Not to drink. Yeah eggs and I did I definitely have done that to my mother before
Oh
Go to sleep go to sleep the poor thing you need to be put out of your misery
Hmm frozen maggots, let's you know take a couple of those you never know crafting. I don't have any crafter shit
What's up
I
Please I can't stand the sound
I need no salvage. Hey, call it to my dad. Sorry
Please stop desist
You're a wretched lamentation. Hey, that's a book in the bible
I don't like that. I don't understand the proddling pates. They freak me the fuck out
Um
This is a scary place. I just wanted to where am I?
Oh, I'm under I'm underground. Oh, well, I'm I know I'm underground, but you know what I mean
Hey
What's up queen? Oh shit, you're coming at me hardcore. I just wanted to grab a key
You guys look so odd. You're like shadow husks key
Thank you
Jail upper level key
Hi queen
You
Someone fucking running at me from behind
Better heard someone running that was weird
It raises me up use it. It's funny
Oh
That's that's very accurate. It is a sound reeflings make around strongy. I I agree with this sentiment
Guys, I don't want to go deeper in the hole. I don't have to pee before I go down there. I think I'll go pee
Yellow that's a color
I
And it was all yellow
You use it to tell bach that he has to ignite the light and just let it shine what the
Gull, I'm gonna ban you
Just because you just make now go to I go to read your sentence without looking at your username
And then you just say the most shit that does not make any fucking sense to me, bro
Are you on crack? Is that what you smoke crack? Is it a crack that you smoke?
I'm kidding. I'm not gonna ban you but I I generally wonder what's go through goes through your head
It's true though. Look it up
My design dad everybody this man created me
He's not yeah, it's like everything has a little bit of truth in them
I hope you guys know I usually will read what you guys are saying before I look at your name
Everything that comes out of his mouth is a shitpost. Anyways, I'm gonna go piss
You
Need to find something to make for lunch
Okay, what can I make for food?
I really want crab legs!
Guys, should I buy crab legs?
Should I order crab legs?
Maybe I'll play Concord and I'll revive it.
I'll revive the entire game with just my presence.
Do I really trust seafood again?
I don't know, man.
That's a great question.
Wait, I have to like see if there's any place that sells it.
Let's take a peek.
I'm going to be Brock for a second from Pokemon.
She's doing torture myself?
It's not torture!
Crab legs are healthy.
I honestly don't really eat red meat.
I usually only eat chicken and fish.
Not that I don't like red meat.
I just really just don't eat it or buy it.
I just don't buy it to cook it.
Crab legs.
How long will this take?
33 minutes?
They have really nice pictures of their food.
Fried corn?
I don't really like crawfish.
There's not a seafood I would not eat.
I'll tell you that right now.
If there's seafood, I will eat it.
I see food, I eat it.
They eat corn the long way?
No, I deep-throat it like it's a fucking glizzy.
It is expensive.
They have Shirley Temple, add that.
I've never had shrimp that I can eat the head off.
I've never eaten shrimp heads.
If I get crab legs, I will literally do a mukbang
and I'll pull up my webcam so you guys can see me eat all this food.
The tests of your love for me will be you watching me destroy crab legs.
I'll tell you right now, crab legs are my favorite food when I was younger.
I know I'm going to sound like a fat fuck right now, but I don't care.
Although it's funny because I would go to China buffet with my dad.
It's just like a buffet place.
They had crab legs and I would just eat plates of crab.
Crab legs are like, crab meat is pretty light, so it's like, I would just get lots of them.
Taxed right off.
Renact the vid of the lady eating crab legs in a truck bed while it's driving.
I've never seen that.
What?
I don't think that means what you think it means.
Let's look through.
Looking through.
Holy shit.
If they have something, they get two lobsters.
What the hell? I don't want lobster though.
I can order alcohol? Oh boy.
Should I just order like a six pack of Mike's hard?
Ooh, but I fucking love Mike's hard black cherry lemonade.
I'm tempted to make really bad decisions on Door Dash right now.
My dad makes scallops so good.
My dad's a pretty good cook.
Lobster. I've never been to red lobster.
No, I'm not going to be tweeting from the toilet.
Guys, I'm not like allergic to like seafood.
I just had bad seafood like one time and you guys think it's going to kill me.
I can have quail eggs. That doesn't make any sense.
Actually, this is not as expensive as I thought it was going to be.
It's actually not bad.
All right, boys.
It's actually not that bad.
I thought it was going to be like over $100.
It isn't actually remotely close to that.
Yeah, even with the 20% on top, quail eggs are all right.
I've seen quail eggs in the grocery store.
I've been tempted to get them for the cats because quail eggs are good for kitty cats.
It's like a nice little meal topper and a calcium from the egg shells is good.
But Boomi's an idiot. He'd probably just choke on something.
So, yeah.
I did it.
I did it, boys. I ordered it.
Mukbang later.
Is it 57 bucks?
Yeah, it's actually, it was actually kind of like around that amount.
It's like 50 something.
So Mukbang stream in about an hour.
Seeing all these crabs and Ellen Rings just making me want to eat something.
I have to clean off my desk.
Well, yeah, when I ordered the McDonald's, everything was cold.
Something, I don't even remember what else happened.
I dropped my keys in the elevator and I still haven't gotten the back yet.
I have a thing of wet ones right next to me because I'm ready to rumble.
Just kidding.
I have the wet ones off to the side to clean my 3DO when I'm sucking on its ears.
Sorry, I'm slipping on my juice box.
Do you guys still love me?
I don't know. You guys, I need reassurance.
Avila Mukbang was not on my bingo card today.
You should, you guys just have an absurd, what's it called?
An absurd bingo card list because I'll probably check off everything on that list.
I'm not lying to you.
You still look, okay, cool. Just checking, just checking.
I get brainwashed all the time.
So you guys know how manhara I am.
You're watching this stream.
I need, I literally just cleaned my mouse pad and I actually replaced it because I destroyed it a couple months ago before I was in v-alert.
And I just got the same one and it's destroyed again.
So I'm actually just going to keep it like that.
Making a lot of space.
I don't know, it just fell.
Making a lot of space on my desk so you guys can get the full appeal.
I can't wait for booing me to come over and try to eat everything.
Cool, I think this is enough room.
I just think you guys are going to think I'm like fat.
I've also been, you know what, since I'm probably going to nuke this bot, I'll be real.
I don't feel like I'm doing too hot in terms of like my performance.
I know I feel like I could be doing better because I just feel like I'm not performing well.
I was just like looking at my numbers and I'm like, what am I doing wrong?
Like I'm not growing at all.
It's really weird.
I'm just, I've just stagnated and I'm just kind of confused by it.
So I'm like, what can I do, you know?
Slurp, slurp, slurp, get you, slurp, slurp, slurp, get you.
Thank you, Leon.
Hi, Amy.
What's up, Amy?
What's up, little sis?
Everybody say hi to Amy.
My gym, my YouTube members and my gym numbers.
I just, I know I can be performing better.
So I'm wondering what I can be doing, you know?
I'm trying to get more sort of shorts out.
I have an ASMR on the way and it's all, all those stuff.
I know, I know it's not really up to me.
It's all those stuff, but you know, I get in my head.
Emington?
Big sis, why are you calling her big sis?
Don't, don't get it twisted.
She's a little sister around here.
Don't disrespect her.
I know, I know.
It's going to come.
I'm just waiting for the algo, the algo to like me.
And I, I didn't try the Wukong game.
I got up on my throne because, you know, I have other priorities
like buying fucking crab legs instead of black meth Wukong.
I'm fucking an idiot.
Why does she, she doesn't, can she just buy her own stuff?
No, I can't.
My priorities are food, water, shelter, bills, cats, stream related stuff.
Stuff that I want.
Maybe we can do an ASMR collab together.
Perhaps that'd be cool.
Maybe like little sister and big sister take care of you.
That'd be cute, actually.
I wouldn't mind that.
Thank you.
And also sometimes again, I get in my head about it because people think I'm like,
I'm very, and I can't blame them because of how abrasive I am in this stream.
For example, um, make money, son buy it for it.
And I can't make my managers don't buy any games for me.
I have to buy all my own games, um, but I own all my own games.
So it doesn't even matter.
Uh, the only game that I had to buy was Titanfall and I got reimbursed from that
by one of you guys, which I, I appreciate it and she didn't have to do that.
So I appreciate it.
Yeah.
I got to tell them to like, comment and subscribe.
That's good.
It's funny because like a strong, you did point out, she's like,
you guys have to remind your, your viewer base to subscribe to you.
And I don't do that often enough because normally I don't care,
but like I, I realize I need to do better at that.
Like I'm like, Hey guys, you need to, if you, if you join my content,
like please subscribe, please.
Cause the sports, the sports means helps in the YouTube algo.
It helps me reach more people, um, commenting anything.
Yeah.
I also need to interact on YouTube more.
That's my own fault.
Uh, I don't like, I'll like and heart some of your messages, your comments,
but I'm just, I just, um, I don't comment a lot and I need to do that more.
I need to comment back to you guys and comment on all my, um,
my coworker stuff, my gen mate stuff and also just people I like.
I know I need to use the community tab more besides posting schedules.
I just, I interact a lot more on Twitter and it's not,
it's stupid because I'm just a V Twitter on my alt account.
And I need to, I need to, I need to focus more on YouTube.
So you make more content aside from streams.
Yeah, I'm work, I, I'm working on that.
I am working.
So it's not like I'm not doing it.
I am working on that.
Just stuff isn't up yet.
It takes time to edit.
Um, like it gets, I hand it off to the management management,
hands off to the editors and the editors got to do their magic.
I have like, I think I have like four or five shorts on the way.
Uh, in fact, I need to ask, I'm going to ask management right now if I,
how my shorts are doing.
Hold on.
And again, there's six of us and multiple editors.
So just take some time.
Um,
Oh my God, there's so many fricking messages in our discord.
What happened?
Are you serious?
Oh, bro.
I mean, I just saw your message in the discord.
I'm, that doesn't make any sense.
No, I just, I just saw what you posted about the collapse of bro.
I'm just, I'm so sick of it.
Oh my God, dude, we're fucking normal on YouTube.
Oh, I fucking hate this.
Sorry, I'm just reading stuff.
Spill the tea.
No, it's just, it's just more stuff that people can't,
can't hang out because of our 18 plus content.
And it's just disheartening.
Um,
but they have to join other ways.
I hate, I hate VT for politics so much.
Yeah.
It isn't really tea.
It's not tea.
It's not bad at all.
It's just like, yeah, it's just stupid.
Um, it happened again.
Like I, we expect like that's not like the people.
I don't even, I just don't get it though.
Cause they were.
Hold on.
Let me, let me message you and me.
And then let me message management like I wanted to.
Hi.
Let me message management like I wanted to.
Hi, how are my shorts and emotes coming along?
I put em emotes.
I'm fine.
No, I don't wanna.
Hey, when I do like a, like a certain emotes,
like a funny face on,
on Discord, autocorrects it to a fucking emoji.
Anyways, at least I'll be happy with my crab legs.
Okay.
Okay, so my emotes should be done next month.
But like early next month.
Okay.
Emotes soon.
Yeah, I ordered emotes a bit ago.
There's going through the other girls' emotes.
Cause again, a lot of us hit,
I got higher memberships.
And so we got more email slots all around the same time.
So,
I think management forgot to send mine out a while ago.
And then they sent out the other girls and then they didn't
mine.
Oh, that's fine.
I don't really care that much.
Oh, thank you, Lex.
Thank you, Lex for the five gifted.
Everybody say thank you if you got one.
Everybody say thank you.
What if I just become a crab?
I must become a crabby bitch.
I'm just kidding.
Oh.
I'm thankful for people giving us a chance nonetheless.
But it is, it's not, it's more like, it's not,
because I know people want to hang out with us.
It's their management telling us that like,
hey, because they do this content
and because there's certain body types in this company,
we can't have you associating with them.
But people think we're fine.
Like they'll talk to us, but they just can't.
It just sucks.
Just sucks a little.
Thank you, Doki for the 10 gifted.
I appreciate it.
I don't know why you guys are gifting subs.
I don't need, it's not,
you guys be like, let's get her more slots.
So she has to order even more emotes.
You sub, thank you for the sub.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
I'm just being really negative right now.
And I apologize for that.
But again, you guys,
you guys appreciate me for my realness
because I'm a real G.
Crab Tuber confirmed for Gen two.
She will do CPT with her big ass gloves.
That'd be funny.
How about Indies?
Again, some, yeah.
Thankfully, like it's literally Indies.
It's, Indies are chill.
Like I had like Fula with such a fucking sweetheart.
This morning she like gifted me some Nitro.
And she's like, here you go.
And I'm like, bitch, what?
Queen?
She's like, yeah, just because.
And I'm like, you're gonna make me cry.
So I'm appreciative of some people.
And you guys like know I like Miwa.
We haven't like collabed, collabed on stream yet,
but we definitely need to do that.
Yeah.
Show a little bit of support.
Oh, thank you.
I don't need anybody.
All I need is my gen mates and you guys.
It's all I need in my life.
It's all I need.
All I need.
Oh yeah.
And then I hang out with like Toma and Chai and Maury.
We have a collab coming up too.
I prefer when VTubers are genuine
discussed behind the scenes topics.
Monkopras, Indies, because of this.
We're not like other corpos
because we're even more transparent.
Ow, my ankle.
I'm like trying to stretch my leg out.
I don't know what I just did.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm not worried.
Like honestly, sometimes like I'll get too many calls.
So like I'll be like invited to this, this and this
and I can't keep track.
And so sometimes I just like to spend time
with you guys or my gen mates.
Yeah, but I'm not even worried about perceptions changing.
I really, it's cause they part perceptions
won't change per se.
Cause if people, cause like we do 18 plus content
maybe they literally just don't want to talk to us
because 18 plus content in general
whether we do it on YouTube or not.
Obviously we can't do it on YouTube cause we be banned.
I just don't get the logic.
But we are a brand risk.
We are a brand risk.
I've had people come into my maros asking me
not to collab with their Indie Oshi
when I've expressed interest
because they don't want me to corrupt them.
I don't know how I would do such a thing
when I am very respectful and understanding
if somebody doesn't like something.
And I'm sure the other girls have gone maros just like that.
And that's fine.
So I'm not worried about people's perception changing.
Cause if they're in, if they're straight forward
to their own own headspace like that
they're not probably going to accept the truth
which is that we're normal people.
But I don't want to linger on the topic anymore
because it's, I've talked about it before.
I've cried about it before.
I've whined about it before.
It's just, it's so fucking repetitive.
I'm being extremely fucking redundant.
So like, it is what it is, you know, if people change,
good, if they don't, whatever.
It's like, I gotta, you know,
how's that order coming along?
I already ordered it.
I'm just, let's see where it's at.
I should have ordered alcohol with it.
Can I still do it?
I can't, but I can add a package pickup
from FedEx for some reason.
Oh, I'm gonna have to put my bra on and go downstairs with it.
Why do they just message me hi?
My dasher just messaged me hi.
Hello?
Don't talk to me.
You're like 20 minutes away.
Why are you talking to me?
Please don't give me a weird dasher.
I don't want a fucking weird dasher.
They just said hi redacted,
but they said hi and then they sent redacted,
which is my name.
I have it.
Imagine.
Can you tell where this place is?
I don't know where it is.
I just ordered from it.
Don't you have a GPS bro?
I believe it's sent me to the wrong address.
I'm going to cry on stream if I don't get my crab legs.
I don't know.
Can I send a picture to my dasher?
I don't know if I can.
Cause I think I found the website.
Oh my God.
How did DoorDash send them to the wrong address bro?
It's not bareful.
It's fucking DoorDash is full.
I'm literally just gonna,
throw myself off my balcony and minecraft for real.
At least I have some lemonade.
I can open the fucking...
Eleanor, you're suspenseful music.
What if the driver was a fan and got shy
when he heard your voice and ran off?
I don't think that's the case.
It's funny.
I have this fear that someone's gonna be able
to tell who I am by my nails.
And if the clothing I'm describing that day,
I'm not even a big VTuber.
I'm pretty, I'm so small.
I'm so nervous that someone's gonna find me
and look at my toes and be like,
and I'm brown and they'll be like,
that's fucking she be cotton bum.
They're gonna look at my purple toenails
and be like, that's her.
And I'm gonna talk, I'm gonna open my talk
and say something and they're gonna be like,
it's fucking you.
I'm gonna be like, shit, I look like a rat right now.
I'm not cute.
I'm not wearing any makeup.
I'm sorry.
You start lying about my appearance.
I'm a white woman.
I'm sorry.
I'm half of a white woman.
Hi, my name is Sheeby Cotton Bum and...
Okay, you're gonna call Dordash.
Sorry, I didn't mean to hit my space bar.
Okay, good luck.
Because it said they confirmed the order.
How can they confirm the order if it doesn't exist?
I don't know.
Is it?
This person is in the wrong spot.
I think my down shirt is just a fucking idiot
because I'm looking at the map.
They're not even near the fucking building
that it's showing on Dordash.
I just...
I can't...
You know what's funny?
Yesterday, I think, what did I get yesterday for food?
I forget what I got.
I ordered something too.
And I, oh yeah, I ordered a burrito.
And I'm like, hey, you can just leave it in the lobby.
And they're like, I can't, I'm coming inside.
And I'm like, you can just leave it in the lobby
and take a picture.
Okay, where do I go?
How do I get up this?
How do I get, how do I get to the elevator?
The door is locked.
I'm like, you can just leave it in the fucking lobby
and take a photo, ma'am.
Please.
Sorry, I'm staring at the Dordash map right now.
He's in a completely different building.
My eye is twitching.
I literally went, where's my controller
that's already broken?
Hold on.
There we go.
That makes you feel a little bit better.
I just whipped it at the ground,
but I whipped it at the carpet
so you couldn't hear it that well
but the first time I forget.
Okay.
If I had a keyboard to break, I would do that too.
If you guys were near me, I'd fucking choke you.
Sorry, I'm just ear-sick.
I woke up and I choose fucking violence today.
I do a joking punch the mic
but I actually might punch it for real.
I don't want to actually hurt my fucking hand
actually punching the mic.
And it's not even, it's just stupidity.
It's just stuff.
Again, my OCD, I can't control something.
It's pissing me off and there's other things happening
and I'm getting frustrated.
Oh my God, dude, just walk down the fucking street.
Do I want to hug?
No.
I want to punch a wall like a white boy right now.
That's what I want to do.
I want to punch a hole through a door
for some drywall and then I feel better.
Can I call him?
I don't want to talk to this idiot on the phone.
Phone calls?
I'm still an introvert.
You think I can talk on the phone
and hold a conversation?
No.
Why do you want me to yell at this person over the phone?
They'll probably use my real name and dox me.
That's lemonade tastes like shit.
Why did I buy that?
That tastes disgusting.
This isn't the honest,
this isn't my juice box of something else.
Do I have a flare gun?
Do I shoot myself in the head with?
No.
Does she be Kyle?
I do have anger issues.
Oh, you're facing the right fucking way.
Now go down the road, dude.
Oh my God, no.
Oh my God.
You're getting your tipper voked, brother.
You're going the wrong direction.
No, yeah, DoorDash didn't send you the wrong way.
You pulled into the wrong parking lot.
You're going the wrong way.
Did I use my feature?
Why the fuck would I use?
They're calling me.
Hold on.
Hello?
It was a fucking spam call.
It wasn't even them.
No, you guys wouldn't be able to hear,
I realize, because I have the volume down.
Punished for fail delivery.
You know what?
Maybe I'll make my ASMR script,
because I was thinking about what for to do my schedule.
Let's do my fucking schedule right now,
so I can distract you by something nice.
Oh, here's a DoorDasher.
Hold on.
Want to hear my customer service voice?
Here you go.
Hello?
Yes, you are.
Well, it was showing me that they were in the,
they were right next to the building.
They just kept going to the wrong one in the wrong parking lot.
So that's, I believe that's on the Dasher.
Okay.
Then I would just like a refund then.
You too.
Bye-bye.
Hold on.
Where's the, where's the controller?
I, where did the controller go?
I don't even know where to fucking put it.
Here we go.
Call me Tyler one.
I don't have anger issues.
I swear.
Again,
mental illness, everybody.
When I have an expectation that isn't met,
I get really fucking pissed off.
Okay.
Fuck yeah.
Fucking refund me.
It's still saying they're preparing my order.
why don't you room she's like she's like I called them they wouldn't give me an address the door dash support
yes as I spent money now I have to wait to get a refund
I don't even know what to say I'm just irritated
it's like I just really wanted something to make me happy
I know I'm being overdramatic but again my brain works in mysterious ways
and I've only had coffee today and I'm just fucking hungry so I'm most I'm hangry that's
really what it is I think it's a three to five business day thing
not gonna have trouble all right let's try again
it's still showing that the order is being made
oh my fucking god the door-dash lady is a fucking idiot dude
I am up the fucking stupidity
oh yeah I'm probably on my period as well let's just let's just chalk it up to PMSing and being
hangry um redacted these to remake your order your dash are into an issue so your order is being
remade I asked for a fucking refund just give me a damn fucking refund
now watch this other dasher is going to go there
and that they're gonna run to the same issue where the GPS is taking them to the wrong place
I'm so fucking tilted it's taking a lot of willpower not to spike my phone
so
let's see if this motherfucker will find it he's going down the street I'm gonna laugh so damn hard
if this person's able to get there get my food and then bring it here
I can't choke anything there's nothing to choke
there's nothing to beat wait there's
I don't know if you heard that
I wonder why she keeps saying people are scared of her I don't know why they say that
no I was beating up a plushie I don't know why it sounded like it was squeaking but it might have
been my chair wait is this person gonna do it is there
I'm dead guys I'm literally fucking dead this new driver is at the location
they're right next to the location so they must be going inside
the fucking dumbass person before this couldn't drive one street over because they're dumb ass and
they're fucking idiot yes they're literally inside the fucking building I can see it on my app
unless it's that and unless it's like the building doesn't exist and this is like sometimes you
know I will say door dash sometimes the stores get added that don't exist anymore
and I'm wondering that if maybe the store doesn't exist although it's showing them in the building
so
shout out competent driver that drove one street over I can't find it do you know where it is
um so it's showing on the map uh that it's literally right next to a street over dude
oh my god they have it they literally grabbed it and they're heading to me
I don't
make that make sense wait am I getting food for free hold on did they refund me
I'm wondering if they gave me free food because I said I had no additional costs so I don't know
if maybe the fucking door dash lady fucked up and then she gave me a refund but also sent somebody
to go get it I I I don't know we'll find out we'll find out in three to five business days
so
free cab legs cheat code just get a dumb ass dude
I can't wait to delete this entire VOD.
Conceal, don't feel, don't let them know.
Oh now they know I'm a hoe.
I'm mentally ill.
I'm one with the wind and sky.
I'm in Hera.
I'm so pissed.
And I don't even know why.
Here I am.
Getting pissed at Door Dash.
At the storm rage on.
I get pissed off at the smallest things.
Dun dun dun.
Um.
Nice.
Don't, uh, don't forget everybody.
Um, Emmy and Strani will be collabing with Junna and Fuyo
Cloverfield.
At 2pm Eastern in about 15 minutes almost.
So if you guys need to pop off and go to see them,
I'm totally understandable with that.
Um, if you want to see some wholesome fun girl content.
Instead of me just raging at Elden Ring and getting pissed over
small things and, you know, go for it.
I understand.
I hope you guys enjoy.
I'm going to keep playing Elden Ring and do a mukbang
for the crab legs that I so deserve.
And we'll see.
I kind of want to see the end of the Door Dash arc.
Oh, my neck hurts.
When I was punching the plushie, I hurt my neck.
As you can see, it's off my body.
I gave myself a headache because I hurt my neck.
God damn it.
Not my arthritis.
Where is it?
Where are they?
I want to see where they are on the map.
Okay, they're like 15 minutes away.
How many runes in the world?
This Door Dash driver is fine.
They're getting a fucking kiss.
And being like, thank you for being competent.
Kidding, I'm not going to kiss a Door Dash driver.
That's disgusting.
It's probably like an old dude.
Let's check on my Tamagotchi.
Oh, wait, it's dead.
Guys, should I pick blue, purple, or green egg?
I've done all three before.
What color egg?
What if they're hot?
No, no, thank you.
Purple, purple, purple, blue, green, blue.
There's no red.
Purple?
Purple to match the nails?
Okay, purple it is.
I'm seeing a lot of purple.
It's cracking?
No, it's not cracking.
It's being selected.
It's in the spotlight.
It's being beamed up.
Okay, it's going to roll around for a bit, and then I'm going to have to spam feed it
because it gets depressed otherwise.
Oh my God, what the fuck did I do to my neck?
Did you guys like the rage?
I'm like a flush street.
I'm like Tyler one.
Or that one dude that just breaks every keyboard.
It was scary.
Why are you scared?
You love me more for the rage?
You like how real I am?
Do you guys still love me even though I have issues?
I need constant reassurance.
I probably have my period.
I'm probably PMSing.
I'm hungry.
I'm sad.
I need reassurance and affection.
Maybe I just need to jack off.
I don't know.
If you love me, please subscribe to my channel.
If you really love me, you can subscribe.
If you get me ice cream, I'll probably just shit myself.
I'm feeling very needy and I need reassurance.
Please just continue to tell me how awesome I am in the chat.
Thank you.
Sorry, I'm slapping my thigh.
Continue on.
I need to be gassed up right now.
Not the placeholder emotes.
Don't worry, you don't have to give me monetary love.
I just need verbal love through text right now.
I said gassed me up, not lied to me.
Shebe's a go-to FPS player.
You don't have to lie to my face.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Hold on, I missed the name because I looked away for a split second.
Thank you, Martin.
It's George R. Martin.
He's watching me right now.
Thank you, Flowerhead, for the remember.
Flowerhead celebrates two months of membership.
Love you, Shebe.
Please don't doubt that.
I'll always be there for you.
Just please don't call me stinky again.
I shower.
Sorry.
But not sorry.
You have voicemail, so you're always stinky.
Guys, stop lying.
You don't have to make fake stories like I saved your cat from your burning house.
I just want to be told things.
It hatched.
Why does it always hatch as a weird blob?
I don't really get that.
There's only like one baby form for Tamagotchi's.
I don't quite understand.
I thought there was going to be like three because I get the same one each time.
Okay, I'm just pumping it full of milk right now.
Okay, it's full.
You better be cute or we're going to have problems.
I've given myself a headache because I hurt my neck.
I'm a little dizzy, but it's fine.
Okay, now you're full.
You're full on food and now I will have you play with the cleaning Zumba.
Oh, thank you.
I appreciate it.
A child looks the same as every child.
You're the first sheep I consistently watch.
That's a thank you for the entertainment.
Oh, thank you.
Feeling like a Tamagotchi blob right now.
I need a bad bitch to pump me full of milk.
I can't wait to probably get sick because like this is how I like everything has just been going wrong with me for the past couple days.
Stuff isn't working.
I have to check if do me turn all downloaded.
Bitch, why are you still crying?
I have to pee again for some reason.
I have to toot.
I don't know if you guys heard that.
I just don't care anymore.
I'm disgusting.
Wait, what?
Let me see.
Come on.
You didn't have to delete that.
It was slightly on topic.
Given the fact I was talking about pumping people full of milk.
He got caught.
Do you want us to have heard it?
No.
It seems like I got muffled so you guys didn't hear.
But I care about you guys and I love you guys.
Thank you for making me happy.
Get positively affirm.
Oh wait, schedule.
Okay.
Help me.
Help me with my schedule for next week.
Okay.
So I already have.
Well, I don't know if that collab is happening anymore.
So we have what do you guys want to do scary movie three for the watch along?
Or did you want to watch something else for the membership stream on September 2nd?
Faith.
Okay.
I have to add faith.
Scary.
Okay.
We'll do scary movie.
So for Tuesday the third, I have do me eternal.
Let's try this again.
So we'll do Tuesday the third do maternal.
I put a hollow cure up.
I don't know.
Okay.
And let's try a mirror up.
I don't know.
If you guys want to watch me play hollow cure because you guys like the wedding which stream.
Would you guys like me to play hollow cure or you're like, I don't really care.
I'm like a lot super set on it.
But if you guys are fine with it, it's fine.
I'll have faith as well.
Okay.
Hello care.
We've got holi care for Wednesday.
in me streaming on Thursday. I can't tell. I don't know if she's also working on her
schedule still. I think she is. Okay, I'll just strutty. You always put your streams
over by. It's hard to like, not, no, I'm not saying like, Oh, I'm mad. She's overlapping.
It's more so that I can't like, I can't just click on the time slot and type something
in. I have to like, go through this whole thing to avoid accidentally clicking on hers.
She be face. He had holy trilogy. Is that what it's called? With heart rate. We'll do
heart rate again. Oh, no, I don't want to move it. I just want to make it longer. Thank
you. Well, I'll just I'll just be guerrilla in Alden Ring. So don't worry about that.
Oh my God, he's approaching with my order boys. Hi, you can just leave it the lobby.
I'll go from the content. Like a meme review. That's a good idea. I don't. Yeah, I think
I just haven't been doing like, I like playing games. I don't do a lot of like,
hand cam stuff or just random stuff. Honestly, I don't know how Amy comes up with the stuff
she does, because I'm always impressed. Because she doesn't play a lot of games. She mostly does
like, excuse me, other stuff, like. I don't even know. Yeah, I need to do add more variety.
Ago just doesn't like me. I already I have dark wood. I do like dark wood, but I don't
dark woods hard for me to focus on.
I don't think I'd like, I would start it and then I don't think I'd be able to finish it. Because
that's what happened last time I tried to play it.
Watch my dash or show up with like, no food. And they're just like, sorry, I ate it.
Okay, more fan fiction.
Should be as grab skin. Maybe
some tearless. What sort of tearless? I don't know.
I don't think it's a genre issue, because I do have a quite a variety of games that I play.
I think I just need to add more variety besides just playing games. But then
Oh, Stronny's playing Titanfall on Monday.
So you guys are gonna see Titanfall twice. Because Stronny's playing Titanfall on Monday,
that's hilarious.
Oh, the people are playing some Elden Ring too.
I'll do ASMR on Saturday.
I don't, I was trying to think of the type of ASMR stream. I've just been like,
I can't, I haven't been able to think of like, what you guys would want to see more of.
Oh, Stronny's doing a members watch along of Tropic Thunder with a foot.
A food tearless. I don't know.
General food, Zassidon. But that's me anyways.
Like, I want to, I want to, I want to do something special for you guys. I want to
give you something that you guys would enjoy. Not stuff I do already.
Assassin's Creed Valhalla?
Feet? What about feet?
But we enjoy what you do already. But I want to do better.
A bartending game?
What? A little Lego? Well, I have the Legos. I still didn't make those.
A visual novel Valhalla? I've never heard of that.
Should I do, maybe I'll do the, should I do the ASMR? You're my delivery person. I just beat the
shit out of you. Actually, you know what? Let's do that. Saturday, ASMR, 4pm, Sheeby.
I don't even know what I would call, name that.
P.O.V., you're my delivery person.
Anybody order some sausage?
You're my doordash?
P.O.V., you're my doordash.
Now I'll put food delivery. I won't call out doordash like that.
Oh my god. All right. I'll have to think of an outfit. I'll just like show up in a robe.
You fucked up my order. You have to come inside in a tone for your sins.
The context will be lost with this mod, probably. Most definitely. People will be like, what?
My manager's posted a discord meme that says, I fear you've been blacklisted.
What's new? I don't stream on Sundays. That's my day off and I have to do some like
applying for housing stuff again. I'm just going to make that a whole day because I can't focus.
Yeah. I just beat you guys. They'll be like, oh, they're thinking like, oh, this is going to be a
no. I'm beating you up for getting my order wrong. Wait, did they even drop it off?
It's been like 10 minutes and this person just walking around my bed. I just told you.
I told you where to leave it.
Hey. Hi. You can leave it at the lobby for you and take a picture. I just said that.
I'm sure what you do. Oh, mod spotted, mod spotted. I didn't see it. What did it say?
I'm looking at my, I'm looking at my VOD.
Who's the mod? Now we can tell who you are.
I'm playing my own VOD.
Oh my, you're lucky. You're lucky my chat froze for the 50th time today.
Somebody just left food at the lobby score. I would actually shoot someone. No, they just assigned a
number. I don't remember the reason why, but it is helpful. I just can't recall why the reason is
helpful. Catch him and tickle his little paws.
Oh yeah. So we can tell who mod, which mod is who because they all have the same name.
Don't snitch the mod. I'm going to go tell management right now that the mod posted
and they're going to be murdered and I'm kidding. I'm not going to do that. I'm just teasing you.
I'm just teasing you.
I hope you have a fun collab in me. I saw a collab, bro. Heart.
All right. Photo? Why the heck? They didn't put it in the right place, but that's fine.
All right. I'll be right back. Jimmy is live. I'm going to, I need to
undo my camera. I'm going to plug in my camera.
How do you move my?
Okay. Crab arrived. We're about to get fucked up, boys. I need to go downstairs. I don't feel
like putting on a bra. It's whatever. I don't know if you heard Boomi speak when I said that.
That was kind of funny. I don't know. Where's my sweatshirt? I'm just going to throw a buddy over him.
Hi, Boomi. Oh, what was that? He just jumped up and headbutted the wall in excitement. That was
adorable. I don't think you meant to do that, but it was quite cute. What time is it? 205? Okay,
you guys are eating an hour. I didn't get anything fucking done today. I'm pissed. I wanted to play
more Elden Rain, but we have Fall of New Vegas. I need shoes. I can't walk around barefoot. My ass
is hanging out. Drive home safely. Are you ready for the mukbang?
No, like, he didn't hurt himself. Like, he was, he, he, don't worry, he's fine.
Hi. Oh, hi. Like, you know how like horses will excitedly like gallop and like kind of like buck?
Boomi does that. He does that. Hi. What's up? I'm, I'll try to record doing it sometime.
Uh-huh. Where are my keys? Where are my keys?
Let's not drop them down the elevator shaft, right? Right, Boomi? Excuse me. I'll trip over you.
Boomi, I'm home.
Okay, I have a Shirley Temple. I'm feeling incredible. What the fuck are you guys talking about?
No, is my internet going?